c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
le shangai et rosie est trop petit
nourrir le petit personnel comme je
m'amuse à dire parce que j'adore ces
filles sont adorables et chaque fois ils
me demandent des cacahuètes et non pas
par moi je les pique dans la loge des
animateurs et voilà les chroniqueurs et
c'est bien à mes films je nourris le
petit personnel c'est la base de mon
grand-père était que tu message toujours
ce très souvent mais c'est pas parce que
je suis un top model pour faire
attention à ne pas tout mettre non plus
oui c'est vrai bien préparé de leur
groupe dit toutefois confiant
[Musique]
alors je ne viens jamais quand je suis
pas prévu mais je sais ce que c'est
c'est essayer de parler comme un jeune
mais ça ça m'amuse c'est d'abord ça fait
rire kelly et tout ce qui peut faire
rire kelly je le fais jeux d'eau mac os
batteux je vais kent pourquoi
pour ken ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
ken daniel moreau ne croyez pas l'image
qu'elle donne c'est une petite [ __ ]
et le dernier mort on peut y aller vas-y
ma fille une bonne main au cul oui oui
c'est vrai
[Musique]
cette fine en faire